CERTAINLY ONE OF THE LONGER
WITNESS INTERVIEWS THE COMMITTEE
HAS CONDUCTED.
TELL OUR VIEWERS WHAT YOU'RE
LEARN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
PAT CIPOLLONE WAS WITH THE
COMMITTEE FOR MORE THAN EIGHT
HOURS WHEN YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE BREAKS HE TOOK.
HE SAT FOR MORE THAN SEVEN HOURS
OF TESTIMONY.
IT DOES COMPARE TO SOME OF THE
MORE LENGTHY TESTIMONY THAT WE
HAVE SEEN BEAR FRUIT FOR THE
COMMITTEE, SUCH AS IVANKA TRUMP,
JARED KUSHNER, THOSE WERE LONG
DEPOSITIONS, THEN LATER USED IN
HEARINGS.
ALSO JEFFREY ROSEN, RICHARD
DONAHUE, MEMBERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THEY ALSO
SAT FOR LENGTHY INTERVIEWS THAT
THE COMMITTEE WAS ABLE TO USE.
THIS WOULD INDICATE THAT
CIPOLLONE WAS, AT LEAST ON SOME
LEVEL COOPERATIVE.
THERE WAS SOME CONCERN HE MAY
NOT ANSWER CERTAIN QUESTIONS
BECAUSE OF PRIVILEGE ISSUES.
THAT MAY BE THE KAY.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN WE LEARN MORE INFORMATION,
BUT AT THE VERY LEAST, IT
APPEARS THAT CIPOLLONE WAS
WILLING TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THERE ARE MANY QUESTIONS THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAD THAT THEY
BELIEVED HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
PRIVILEGE CONCERNS, ABOUT A LOT
OF THE ISSUES THAT TOOK PLACE
LEADING RIGHT UP THROUGH JANUARY
6th.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE, WOLF, WHETHER
OR NOT ANY OF THESE DEPOSITION,
WHICH WE KNOW WAS VIDEOTAPED,
APPEARS IN UPCOMING HEARINGS AS
SOON AS NEXT WEEK.
>> RYAN, CIPOLLONE CERTAINLY
KNOWS MORE THAN ALMOST ANYONE
ABOUT WHAT FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS DOING ON JANUARY 6th
AND IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS
LEADING UP TO JANUARY 6th.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT, HAS
KEY INSIGHT INTO SOME OF THESE
BIG ISSUES THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS BEEN TRYING TO UNPACK,, LIKE
THE EFFORT TO INSTALL JEFFREY
CLARK.
THERE WAS ALREADY TESTIMONY THAT
HE THREATENED TO RESIGN IF THAT
WAS THE CASE.
ALSO THE CONDUCT ON JANUARY 6th
ITSELF.
HE WAS VERY FEW NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY HAD ACCESS TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL DINING ROOM WHERE
DONALD TRUMP WAS REPORTEDLY
HOLED UP DURING THE
INSURRECTION.
JUST HOW MUCH OF THAT INSIGHT
HE'LL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
HE HAD REGULAR INTERACTION WITH
PEOPLE LIKE MARK MEADOWS, JOHN
EASTMAN, JEFFREY CLARK, MEMBERS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
ALL KEY PLAYERS WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS INVESTIGATION THAT THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IS TRYING
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF.
>> RYAN NOBODY ELSE, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
>>> LET'S BRING IN MAGGIE
HABERMAN, CORRESPONDENT FOR "NEW
YORK TIMES," ALONG WITH SHAN WU.
WHAT DOES IT SAYING, MAGGIE,
THAT THE INTERVIEW LASTED MORE
THAN SEVEN HOURS.
CERTAINLY WE HAVE SEEN A LOT OF
THESE INTERVIEWS RUN A LONG
TIME.
JARED KUSHNER'S RAN LONG, IVANKA
TRUMP.
A LOT OF THEM HAVE RUN LONG.
WE DON'T KNOW THE QUESTIONS.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY TRIED TO
DRILL DOWN ON WHAT CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON TESTIFIED TO.
WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY TRIED
TO ASK QUESTIONS BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF WHAT WAS UNDERSTOOD
THAT WOULD BE ASKED AND WHETHER
CIPOLLONE TRIED TO TALK ABOUT
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
IF THE COMMITTEE DID NOT ASK
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS, I'M NOT SURE
HOW FORTH COMING CIPOLLONE WOULD
HAVE BEEN ON HIS OWN.
>> SHAN, WHAT DOES IT SAY TO YOU
ABOUT THE LENGTH OF THE
VIDEOTAPE.
WHAT DOES IT SAY ABOUT THE LEVEL
OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE THAT
CIPOLLONE MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
PLAYED.
>> IT'S HARD TO INFER, AS MAGGIE
WAS SAYING, OBVIOUSLY ASKED A
LOT OF QUESTIONS.
THESE ARE VERY SKILLED
QUESTIONERS.
IF CIPOLLONE THINKING HE WAS
SKILLFUL ENOUGH TO DANCE AROUND
THINGS, NOT GIVE OUT DAMAGING
INFORMATION, PROBABLY IS
MISTAKEN.
EVEN IF HE TRIED TO INVOKE
PRIVILEGE, HE WASN'T DOING THAT
FOR THE ENTIRE SEVEN HOURS.
THERE WAS A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
PRIVILEGED WHERE HE DIDN'T TRY
TO INVOKE THAT PROTECTION.
WHATEVER HE THINKING OF IT, THE
QUESTIONERS USUALLY FIND MORE
VALUE IN IT THAN THE PERSON
BEING QUESTIONED REALIZES.
>> MAGGIE, AS I MENTIONED,
CIPOLLONE'S TESTIMONY WAS
RECORDED ON VIDEO.
IT'S POSSIBLE THE COMMITTEE WILL
CHOOSE TO PLAY PORTIONS OF IT
DURING FUTURE HEARINGS.
THERE'S GOING TO BE AT LEAST ONE
HEARING NEXT WEEK.
HOW SIGNIFICANT WOULD THAT BE?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMITTEE,
WOLF, AND PART OF WHY THEY
WANTED THIS TESTIMONY DONE
TODAY, AHEAD OF NEXT WEEK'S
HEARING.
WE THINK 24RKD BE A HEARING ON
THURSDAY, BUT THAT'S TBD.
PART OF THAT IS WHAT THEY GET
OUT OF THIS TESTIMONY TODAY.
AS WE HAVE SEEN, THE HEARINGS
ARE SCRIPTED, VERY TIGHTLY
STRUCTURED.
THEY END UP USING THESE SNIPPETS
OF VIDEO IF THEY HAD A LIVE
INTERVIEWEE, THEY MIGHT GET
SOMETHING DIFFERENT BACK WHEN IT
WAS A HEARING SETTING, AS
OPPOSED TO A VIDEOTAPED
INTERVIEW.
THEY'VE BEEN USING THEM FOR
THEIR PURPOSES TO TELL THEIR
STORY.
I DO EXPECT THEY PROBABLY GOT
SOMETHING.
WE JUST DON'T HOW MUCH AND WHAT
IT WOULD BE.
>> WE'LL FIND OUT SOONG.
SHAN, COULD CIPOLLONE HAVE
REVEALED ENTIRELY NEW
INFORMATION THAT THE COMMITTEE
HASN'T LEARNED FROM?
>> CERTAINLY COULD HAVE.
HE'S IN A UNIQUE POSITION.
THERE CERTAINLY COULD BE
INFORMATION THAT HE'S PRIVY TO,
OR MORE IMPORTANTLY, COULD
REALLY EXPAND UPON AND FILL IN
DETAILS.
I'M RELATIVELY CONFIDENT.
IF IT WAS A PRIVATE
CONVERSATION, HE WOULD TRY TO PO
THE UP ROAD BLOCKS, BUT AGAIN,
BECAUSE OF HIS POSITION, THERE'S
A LOT OF DETAIL THAT POSSIBLY
ONLY HE WOULD KNOW, BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WOULD BE THE BEST
SOURCE TO CORROBORATE.
>> MAGGIE, CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ
CHENEY SAID FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS ALMOST CERTAINLY NOT
HAPPY ABOUT CIPOLLONE ACE
TESTIMONY.
DOES HE HAVE MAJOR REASONS TO BE
NERVOUS RIGHT NOW?
>> I DON'T THINK HE HAS -- IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO SAY.
IT'S HARD TO SPECULATE ON WHAT
CIPOLLONE MAY HAVE TOLD THEM.
"MAJOR" IS THE WORD THAT STRUCK
ME.
I'M NOT SURE HOW MUCH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HIMSELF IS AGITATED
ABOUT THIS TESTIMONY.
I THINK HE WAS ANNOYED WHAT I
HEARD FROM A COUPLE PEOPLE, BUT
I THINK HE HAS PEOPLE IN HIS EAR
SAYING THAT HE SHOULD BE MORE
ANNOYED.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
CORRELATE TO WHAT CIPOLLONE MAY
HAVE ACTUALLY SAID.
COULD HE SAY A LOT OF THINGS
THAT COULD BE PROBLEMATIC?
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
DID HE?
THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION.
>> MAGGIE, YOU'RE ONE OF THE
BEST REPORTERS HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
I ASSUME TRUMP IS OBSESSED,
WATCHING ALL OF THIS ON
TELEVISION?
>> HE'S NOT WATCHING ALL OF
THEM, IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
I THINK HE'S CAUGHT SOME OF
THEM, SUMMARIES OF OTHERS.
AS MUCH AS HE IS A TV CONSUMER
AS HE IS, HE ALSO HAS -- AND
HEADLINE CONSUMER, HE HAS OTHER
PEOPLE RELAY HEADLINES TO HIM.
HE'S VERY USS SEPTEMBER I7B8 TO
HAVING HIS PIN SHAPED, AS YOU
KNOW.
THESE HEARINGS ARE NOT ACTUALLY
SET UP FOR HIM TO BE PART OF THE
AUDIENCE.
>> CASSIDY HUTCHINSON, WHOSE
POWERFUL TESTIMONY WE ALL
WATCHED, HOW DOES SHE PLAY INTO
THIS?
>> I THINK WE HAVE SEEN THE
COMMITTEE TO USE HER TO TELL A
DIFFERENT SIDE OF THE STORY.
I THINK SHE TOLD VARIOUS PIECES
NOT KNOWN BEFORE.
THE COMMITTEE TRADED HER
INFORMATION AS NEW AND
INCREDIBLY RELEVANT.
SHE TOLD A LOT OF DETAILED
PIECES THAT HAD NOT BEEN HEARD
BEFORE.
THIS WAS THE COMMITTEE LEADING
HER THERE.
SHE SPOKE TO SOMETHING THAT SHE
HAD-SECONDHAND KNOWLEDGE OF,
THIS POSSIBLE CONFRONTATION IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL SUV, BUT I DO
THINK THE COMMITTEE THINKING HER
TESTIMONY IS HUGELY IMPORTANT.
GOING FORWAR